welcome to the man of recaps this is the
flash season six
since the beginning of season one we
knew that one day flash would disappear
in crisis but all the time travel antics
flash has gotten up to over the years
has altered the timeline
crisis is happening this season in fact
barry gets a visit from the monitor who
they met during the elseworlds crossover
last season and he has some bad news for
barry the flash won't just disappear
in order for billions to survive this
coming crisis
the flash must die but they have a few
weeks before crisis so in the meantime
it's normal shenanigans a new speedster
villain called godspeed shows up we met
him last season in the nora's future
flashback the flash easily captures him
but turns out he's a robot in fact
they've caught like four of them
godspeed mystery is not resolved this
season it may be a big part of season
seven another big problem are a bunch of
black holes appearing in central city
turns out youtuber scientist chester p
runk accidentally turned himself into a
black hole so the flash has to stop a
black hole the only way he knows how by
running really fast and punching it in
the face
somehow this actually works and chester
has to cool off for a while but by the
end of the season he joins team flash as
a science guy
dr caitlin snow feels bad for her icy
alter ego killer frost that she only
comes out to fight metahumans so caitlyn
offers to take a backseat in their body
this season and let killer frost just
live here to be her life coach is the
elongated man ralph dibny with the book
of ralph first things first they decide
to drop the killer she's just frost now
and she spends the season trying to
figure out who she is besides just
caitlyn's alter ego at the end of last
season vibe decided he didn't want his
powers anymore took the metahuman cure
so now he's just cisco ramon genius
level intellect he's living the dream
with his great new girlfriend camilla
but one night it's danny trejo coming
into his bedroom again remember he's
breacher his ex-girlfriend gypsy's
father and he's got some bad news
gypsy was murdered turns out her killer
was an evil cisco doppelganger but long
story short our cisco outsmarts him now
you can't have a season of the flash
without a harrison wells this season
it's an indiana jones adventurer type
who calls himself nash per usual at
first he and cisco don't get along but
it's like hey man we do this every
season by the end we're going to be best
friends
now the main villain of the first half
of the season is dr ramsay rosso whose
mother just died of blood cancer this
makes him real sad cause this dude
really loved his mom and my mother
a mom mom just like mom i lost my mother
my mother's my mother my mom just like
mum he's got the same blood cancer and
tries to cure it with dark matter which
as you might expect does not go well i
don't want to use the term vampire but
he does go around sucking out everyone's
blood anyone who kills this way turns
into an undead thrall so pretty soon
he's got zombie apocalypse in central
city ramsay thinks he's the hero in all
this because he's cured death but the
good guys don't normally turn into ugly
giant zombie monsters but the flash
takes him out the only way he knows how
by running real fast and punching him in
the face
and now it's finally here the mega
crossover all these cw shows have been
leading to
crisis on infinite earths long story
short the wave of anti-matter energy is
destroying the entire multiverse so all
our heroes come together to stop it
turns out this is all nash well's fault
when he accidentally released the
anti-monitor his high-tech antimatter
wave is actually just powered by a dude
on a treadmill that's not the jay
garrick flash from r3 it's the same act
though he played the flash in the
original 90s series but anyway this is
it to save the multiverse barry's gotta
sacrifice himself
of course though old flash immediately
figures out the obvious loophole novu
said the flash must die in crisis he
never said which one and so 90 slash
takes one for the team and sacrifices
himself to save the multiverse turns out
though that was totally pointless the
multiverse is destroyed anyway a select
few heroes travel to the dawn of time to
face down the ante monitor it's a big
cgi battle anti-monitor 1v1 is the green
arrow oliver queen who long story short
defeats him but dies
somehow though his sacrifice restarted
the universe but not a multiverse it's
been condensed into one
earth prime this has some interesting
repercussions though the timeline was
rewritten so that they've always lived
on the same earth the flash timeline was
convoluted enough with all the time
travel shenanigans they get up to but
now
anything's possible it's a full cw burst
reboot any villain could come back now
for example harley rathaway the pied
piper who was a season one villain when
season three flashpoint changed the
timeline he was actually a good guy but
now he's a villain again and no one
remembers why but now team flash saves
his boyfriend from some science thing
and he helps him out he's a good guy
again and of course one episode gorilla
grodd comes back but this season he
claims he feels bad about being a
villain so he and flash team up to
escape his mental prison maybe groud's a
good guy now
now the main plot this season begins
with allegra garcia a young met a human
with ultraviolet light powers she's
wanted for murder and d.a cecil horton's
prosecuting her but with her new
mind-reading powers she knows allegra's
innocent turns out the killer was her
evil cousin esperanza who got the same
powers and is now a meta human assassin
cecile helps clear her name in fact she
quits her job as the da and becomes a
meta-human defense attorney by the way
iris officially starts her own online
newspaper the central city citizen
cisco's girlfriend camilla joins as a
photographer and allegra joins as an
intern turns out there's a big cover-up
around who hired her cousin esperanza so
team central city citizen is on the case
turns out they're dealing with a super
secret criminal organization called
black hole who employs a bunch of
light-themed assassins the investigation
leads them to mcculloch technologies and
the leader of black hole is their ceo
joseph carver one night iris is snooping
around his dead wife even mcculloch's
old office she finds a mysterious mirror
and oh what's this hoe
pulled into it turns out diva is not
dead she's trapped in the mirror verse
yes she was blown in here the night of
the particle accelerator explosion she's
a brilliant scientist but she's tried
everything there is no escape and no one
knows iris is missing because mirror
iris has taken over her life pretty soon
camilla discovers her secret and gets
turned into a mirror clone too
they're both controlled by eva who is
the main villain has some master plan
and their motto is success is assured
meanwhile frost is hit by a light bullet
her icy healing she should be okay but
she's not so she leaves this season to
go figure out why the elongated man
ralph dibny is still a private
investigator on the side he's searching
for missing heiress sue dearborn
eventually he runs into her and a
classic explosive meets cute at first
she claims she's on the run for mad guys
but turns out she's actually a jewel
thief but turns out she's stealing from
black
hole yes black hole was blackmailing her
parents she's trying to take him down so
they're actually on the same side but a
huge downside of combining the universes
is that we've lost a whole multiverse of
harrison wells some of whom were our
team's best friend
this new grumpy treasure hunter nash is
the only wells left or is he apparently
all the other harrison wells are in his
head somehow unfortunately one of the
harrison wells is actually eobard thawne
the reverse flash
he possesses nash so our team has an
exorcism they go inside his head and
help him face his worst memory now for
some reason nash took a real interest in
allegra became a good mentor to her
turns out that's because he was already
the mentor to one of her doppelgangers
yes she was his protege but during the
tomb raider mission oh she died
so facing this memory exercises thon
who's blasted out as lightning because
he's part of the reverse speed force he
can never really die he's floating
around out there like voldemort
meanwhile there's something wrong with
barry's super speed turns out the speed
force is dying from crisis-related
shenanigans i didn't realize the speed
force could die but i guess it can so
sad
team flash dress creates an artificial
speed force which is apparently a thing
but it's real hard to do they don't
succeed yet so in the meantime barry
starts wearing a watch that shows how
much speed he's using evil mirror iris
realizes that emotional stress makes him
use more so she breaks up with him oh
sad barry and so the mirror people
continue eva's evil plan which involves
the villain from the first half of the
season blood work
and our only will is to serve our mother
he's like oh yeah you're speaking my
language they let him out of his cage
and he gives them some of his blood but
he decides to stay put for now he's
playing the long game indeed after mira
iris puts his blood on a mirror or some
of it's left over so watch out for that
but now barry has got mirror iris
red-handed so she goes all terminator 2
and blades yah then without his speed he
can't stop her oh she stabs him but
barry defeats her with his real
superpower
emotional heart to hearts that convince
villains to find the goodness within
she's not a real person though so eva
just deletes her and now mirror lady
is back in the real world the next part
of her plan is to kill her husband she's
mad at him for leaving her trapped in a
mirror all these years he has a safe
house with his charlie's angels light
assassins but there's way too many
reflective surfaces around so he gets
team flash to protect him the enemy of
your enemy and all that the light
assassins all agreed to work for eva now
and there's a big old battle but it's
all pointless when eva the rings out of
the tv
flash jumps in to save her husband but
she pulls a first-class magneto and oh
stabs him through barry she announces to
the world hey i'm not actually dead and
takes over mcculloch tech but
unfortunately she frames her husband's
murder on sue dearborn meanwhile in the
mirror verse iris tracks down camilla
together they try to escape but iris has
been in here too long oh she's starting
to see things mirror-wise well she
disappears
and that's where season six comes to an
end on a cliffhanger
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member